[Music]
and only in Japan news there's a lot of
only in Japan's there's a [ __ ] ton of
only in Japan that's why it's its own
news section what do you think is
distinctly Japanese cuz underwear
sniffing happens all over the world
[ __ ] robot marrying panties in a
vending machine you want marry robots
here I just don't think you can't which
i think is wrong but I don't know what
the percentage of that is marrying
cartoon I have some cat married his
laptop a couple years ago and had like a
ceremony oh yeah I like an Arizona yeah
oh you heard I thought you had like you
knew someone no no I don't know I think
we did the article here no one ever
knows the people who married their
computers that's why they marry the
computers submitted by window shopper it
Japanese idols are selling their used
bath water for nine hundred dollars a
bottle Oh
nine hundred idols like as in stars but
ya know they're like they're like
bootleg k-pop stars bootlegs yeah they
are they're not they're j-pop yeah
they're J pop it like uh like girl
groups like kpop and then where's J pop
and see Papa what's Chinese one I think
kpop is like Japanese and Chinese pop is
like kpop is Michael Jackson yeah what
about a pop American Bob I don't know
that's a different world I mean it's
still here I think Katy might even be
like this it might be at the top top
Taylor you like this are like barely
like it's it's I think it's different
right cuz like when you see kpop it's
like I would consider them what to be
kind of regular people right like Idol
pop I think it's like some type of girl
girl group worship but what's weird to
me is their fan base there's a lot of
middle aged man that go and and they
idolize these girl groups that are like
in their team oh it is surprised to hear
that but they're not it's not sexual
it's just weird course it's sexual
they're just humble they're just like
very scared man yeah I guess so yeah or
the really polite pervert guys yeah yeah
but it's like but it's it's like
it is still perverted but they're not
it's not like I'm jacking off every
[ __ ] day it's like this it's almost
like put your graduation yeah it's like
an eight year old boy that is has a
crush but he's stuck in a fifty year old
man because he has low emotional IQ
that's the creepiest [ __ ] we're like
it's the guy the polite guy who hires a
hooker and then the whole time he's
[ __ ] her he asked us this is okay
what I think is these guys are too
afraid to even have sex like they're so
emotionally stunted they're like they're
like children and it's so weird we saw
like a thing on YouTube they were
covering the population in Japan and
they were saying like something like 40%
of people even men in Japan are grossed
out by sex contact completely yeah 40%
it was a big night you won't make it to
generation well there's a population
problem and people weren't [ __ ]
people aren't popping out babies and
there's a lot of different factors to it
but there's also this weird phenomenon
that's happening where they're just
staying in their rooms and not going out
working or doing anything - because I
think part of our human instincts like
to procreate how does that morefox yeah
that's kind of happening here - where no
one's going to anymore you're staying in
the room yeah don't want to [ __ ] I'm
sure yes you want to [ __ ] what they were
saying is like some people are [ __ ]
like on those like quick hookup ones but
they're also [ __ ] video games they're
also [ __ ] robots they're also [ __ ]
vending machines yeah yeah she's talking
about well that's the asexual or what do
you call it like the ones that don't
even want a relationship buying live
catfish they're [ __ ] that yeah
they're not getting any form of release
they don't even care about sex yeah I
know somebody like that
it wasn't 40 percent of the male
population it was 40 percent of people
who are single or something like that
yeah yeah yeah that is slightest yeah
yeah number it was it was yeah it was
crazy it's happy globally because I know
like birth weights are slowing
everywhere yeah the [ __ ] robots is
what's happening this bathwater thing
here so
two idols from this J pop girl group
named the banana banana monkeys they are
selling bottles filled with their
bathwater for nine dollars each oh
they're so happy about it oh this is the
banana monkeys and then these are the
two girls and this is the bottle that
they're selling also they took a shower
together so that's the bathwater of two
chicks yes I picture like the nice piece
guy [ __ ] chugging that [ __ ] they're
fully clothed in the water - I think
you're like a William Hung guy getting
an Amazon package and then he gets the
little bottle what's he doing it you
just know they're saying yeah yeah
that's for drinking oh and for or you
with the purple and the so there's like
soap in purple I know but they're saying
like you can drink in you can you can
have them like them part of you internet
or you can dump this bottle nine hundred
dollar bottle in the bathtub with you
and you could be bathing with these
women that's how they're it's pretty
weird dude
how did One Direction not do this at
their height and there's email you know
many girls would have paid money for
their [ __ ] bath water should I
probably still pay for bath water if it
came from Tom Hardy see you want Tom
Hardy's bathwater where I go in the bath
water with yeah who's hot who's
bathwater would you want no I was just
thinking about like what's the normal
version of this and I'm like I guess
it's kind of like people willing to pay
a lot of money for babe and break like
baseball glove no yeah cuz it's like
it's like you're just one degree of
physical contact away so I'm actually if
you think about it that way it's not
that weird yeah that's true cuz everyone
used to sell the [ __ ] celebrity sweat
or like yeah we're like the clothes or
whatever like John Mayer like auctioned
off his guitar I'm sure someone would
buy it right this - this fingers has
been on it gusting his bathwater
yeah right I just want the closer and
closer and closer you got pretty weird
Neil Armstrong his barber used to take
the hair from after cutting his hair and
then he would like sell it cause it's
like this guy walked on the moon he's
the first man on the moon you could sell
a [ __ ] and it had value yeah
this one reminds me more of the perverts
that ask the ladies like for toe crusts
what no yeah I've heard of that you know
yeah like they'll be like oh I want you
to run in your [ __ ] gyms gym socks
all day and then send it to me like
that's what it reminds me pay for
insertion second yeah I guess the
closest thing I've ever been to that is
well we went to Houston and we were in
the Mission Control we got to see and
they have kept the original seat from
like that whole time and I sat in the
sea where the Queen set so I was like
this you're rubbing your ass on it real
hard like give me some royal no you
[ __ ] nose I could relate to what you
guys are talking about okay yes I just
think this is the more extreme version
of it but I think the cops
concept of it isn't that crazy I picture
like an old-ass dude with the bottle and
then he's in the [ __ ] shower and he's
just [ __ ] rubbing her all over him
good it's so pro her vagina was in that
water yeah and then he's got some of
that water it's like that vagina you
just hear the running water and you hear
his halogen light kind of flickering a
little bit God really in there I'm there
with this guy it smell his house now
it's that stale smell cuz like he washes
his clothes but not really with the
detergent so it's just like skin and
feeds TV dinners there that's like the
lowest form of guy like it's like if
he's like lightly moaning while you
shower yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
like the what do you call it sad there's
like there's like guys that that
actually get ladies right like the top
top guys and then there's like rich guys
that like get into relationships and
marriage and like whatever and then you
have the lowest of the low guys like and
these guys are the gremlins of men and
then these are the kind of guys that
would do that they're too weird for the
herd yeah they're just heard of women we
put down though
thousand percent why do we keep them
alive and their disgusting little house
the freaking freedom its soul and that
is Grendel it's crazy though sometimes a
lot of them you don't even know who they
are like they could be your local
librarian or like they might be that
nice right there in the local library
and they still have some value I'm
talking about the creepiest [ __ ] that
Steve was painting you know what I mean
like look they're just a burden to their
parents yeah like they don't do anything
right yeah then they like kidnap women
and just like [ __ ] keep them hostage
why they lick their have the initiative
there even to [ __ ] to do that I have
the initiative the kidnap so they so
they look at pictures online of toes
they're like cockroaches human [ __ ] too
afraid of social interaction for even a
kid exist though man I think I think I
think all the ladies here are like look
at all our [ __ ] DM yeah they like
Dahmer dude Dahmer used to kill joggers
and then he would just like lay next to
them and [ __ ] yeah cuz he didn't he
didn't know how to interact obviously
because they're [ __ ] dead have you
guys been watching that Ted Bundy tapes
no I want to see it but Nicky it was
late night and she didn't want to watch
it cause she'd be scared
oh but he's already gone though someone
said it was scary I heard it oh I mean
you watch scary [ __ ] all the time Don
yeah I want to see that [ __ ] the movie I
want to see the movie when it comes out
the one that they made with what's his
name but he basic oh it doesn't come so
like November or something he I think he
[ __ ] and killed like 36 weeks you know
this whole time
I've just trans man I had a girlfriend
would be like the girl couple
girlfriends yeah yeah but like no that
one though when he got caught oh yeah
you had a daughter
yeah she had like yeah do you think that
he's hot too because they all like all
the Internet's been abuzz really a lot
of girls find them on Twitter saying
sorry well that's how he got a lot of
women too though is because he acted
bunny oh the serial killer
he's kind of like 70s hot at a certain
age but like not his whole life like he
was kind of ugly and then he was kind of
okay he's [ __ ] my Dahmer oh yeah yeah
I'm sorry I'm leaving you hanging
confession he was a killer how about
Charles Manson did you think he was hot
because he always had a lot of ladies he
creepy no I mean like before he put the
swastika on his forehead ladies though
oh okay okay
but Ted Bundy's ladies though they were
all hot especially his first girlfriend
in college the California's like like
rich girl I was like how the [ __ ] did he
get her yeah I know see that goes to
show that girls love Psychopaths oh yeah
I am NOT a psychopath I am a sociopath
that is different than my path
what are you doing something Bart for
sure bro you're a literal pain fighter a
literal path yeah I bet my cutie pass on
your cutie pad what what what is it what
do you think what it order what does
Bart symptoms uh straightforward I've
got a great ass they take things
literally and they're straightforward
and it got ass Asperger's astronaut
that's what it is